Phil, John, congratulations.
You guys have landed
in the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
The partisan.
[gasps]
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Today's day 1.
And the main thing I want
to get accomplished today
is forging out that socket.
If I don't get that done, that's
going to put me behind where
I need to be for tomorrow.
What do you think of that?
Why does it have a hole?
Because the spear
is going to go inside.
For the blade, I'm starting
out with a good chunk of sheet
steel, 1095 high carbon.
There we go.
I am overcome with joy
with the amount of progress
that I've made today.
First thing we got to do is
get the profile established,
get our medial ridge ground
in, take a lot of the weight
out, and get it
ready for heat treat.
A weapon like this
is meant to be swung,
so it needs to be well balanced.
It can't be too top heavy.
But I need to balance that
with strength as well.
So the plan for heat
treating the blade
is to clay up each blade
individually and differentially
harden the edges
so that it stays
nice and soft and
springy, and only
our cutting edge gets hard.
If the whole blade was
as hard as the edge,
it would be really
likely to break.
All righty.
Well, it's straight.
Now we're going to
clay and heat treat
the flanges one at a time.
Last quench right here.
Hell yeah.
Thing's hard as woodpecker lips.
Today is day 2.
And the plan for today is
just to get that medial ridge
situated just right.
And what I've got to figure
out is how exactly to do this.
Smiths have been making
medial ridges for hundreds
if not thousands of years.
But in all of my
research that I found,
I could not find how
they traditionally
put medial ridges on blades
that were so pronounced.
So I'm really having to go
just a little different route
than I think what is
traditionally done.
I'm going to take bar
stock, tack weld it,
throw it in the forge, forge
weld it, throw a bead of weld,
and then I'm going to go in and
clean up those welds so I get
those really drastic curves.
The weight of the piece
is going to be heavier,
but I'm going to have
structural integrity.
That is sufficiently ground.
I think we are
ready to heat treat.
[music playing]
I think we are good.
It's day 4.
The sun's finally out.
Today's mostly refining
work, fit and finish,
getting everything
cleaned up, sharpened,
and getting the sphere mounted.
So now I'm forging a nail to
affix the sphere to the shaft.
So I've just got a piece of
square stock, taper it down.
We're going to cut it
off on the parent bar
and chuck it up
with a nail header.
There's our nail.
I could do better.
See how the head's off center?
I don't know this one.
It's going to be inside--
you're not going to know.
It's fine.
Oh, god, I'll know, though.
I'm going to make another one.
[rock music]
That one's better.
What my spear
brings to the table
is the good blend of
form and function.
And with the way I
made it, it should
be pretty much indestructible.
Feels good.
The plan for today is to
clean up the surface grind,
get everything nice
and shiny, then
continue on with the bevels,
and then start assembling.
I'm just going to
kind of do a dry fit
and see where I'm at
with the pole here.
Not going to peen it.
I still need to take it all
apart for some more work,
but just getting that step
in the process done and ready
to move forward with it.
Whoops.
I'm thinking, yeah,
it'll come right off.
No problem.
I was wrong.
It's like, why am I taking
this out if it fits so well?
But to keep working
on it, I need it out.
Wow.
I'm an idiot.
[grunts]
That's not budging.
As I'm prying on this vise,
trying to get the bar out,
it dawns on me,
heat up the metal.
Burn the wood.
It'll come right out.
Voila.
Disaster averted.
Of all the things
to go wrong, right?
A major build,
$10,000 on the line.
He prematurely gets his
wooden staff stuck in it.
So I'm not planning
on testing right now.
If it's going to
malfunction, if it's
going to break at this
point, I want the judges
to have the honor of destroying
something that I've built,
not me.
I think that feels good.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the kill test.
To test the lethality
of your weapon,
I will deliver killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Phil, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir, man.
Let's do it.
Going into this test,
my heart's starting
to pump a little faster.
Doug's hopefully just going to
destroy this ballistics dummy,
and we're going to have pieces
flying all over the place
and blood on the walls.
[rock music]
All right, Phil.
The design you
have here is scary.
That's a very thick spine you
have, and the edges are sharp.
As you can see, very deadly.
The one thing about
this is that it's heavy.
That is something to take into
account when you're carrying
something like this
into battle and you've
got to move multiple times.
But more importantly,
your weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir
All right, John.
Your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
I'm feeling good
about the kill test.
I know my blade is sharp, and
I think it'll cut really well.
[rock music]
[laughs]
Pushed out a rib.
All right, John.
I love the feel of the blade.
You can really fight with
it because it's lighter.
Your blade also is very
slim that it penetrates
in there when there's
no resistance,
even enough to push out a rib.
More important, I love the
balance, I love the feel,
and it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test--
the pike, push, and armor stab.
Now, the partisan was often used
in castle or in city defense,
so to test the overall
strength and construction
of your blades, I'll be
pushing against these pikes
with the blade and then
stabbing into the armor.
Now, this test is not about what
your weapons do to the targets.
It's about what those targets
are going to do your weapons.
Phillip, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[rock music]
All right, Phillip.
This thing is a beast.
The weight, the
shape of your tip
really makes it a good
penetrating weapon.
The issue I have is the
partisan was a standoff weapon.
You got to be able
to control it.
And at full extension, that
weight is hard to control.
I like the fact that you
have this high medial ridge.
I like your design.
My only issue is the weight.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
John, you ready?
Let's do it.
I am a little bit
worried about the blade
going into the strength test.
Stabbing at armor with the
blade being as thin as it is,
I was really concerned about
keeping the weight down.
Hopefully it holds up.
[rock music]
[bleep]
OK, John, the weapon is light.
It's well balanced.
I really like that.
The issue I have is down here.
It looks as if this
is the thinnest spot.
Now, you've got a
differential heat treat.
You can actually
see those lines.
And that soft core may be
what's affecting this blade.
So as soon as I stabbed in and
it locked up, that blade went.
With this bend, it's not safe
to test this blade anymore.
It's going to keep on
bending, and it's going to get
harder and harder to control.
John, your blade has suffered
a significant deformation
in the course of
our strength test.
It's received a vote of no
confidence from the judges.
I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
I completely agree with
the judge's decision.
With the way that blade
bent, I wouldn't be
comfortable testing it either.
Good job.
Awesome job.
Seriously.
Even though I'm not a
"Forged in Fire" champion,
I am proud of the
work I turned in.
Phil, congratulations, brother.
You did a great job,
and I'm happy for you.
Phillip, you are the new
"Forged in Fire" champion.
That's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]
I just won "Forged in Fire."
John, you're an awesome
dude, an amazing competitor.
The sense of joy
and accomplishment,
knowing my daughter
is going to see,
there's so many
emotions right now.
There's-- I'm overwhelmed.
I'm trying to hold
back tears, man.
I'm taking it home to Texas.
[music playing]